what is Jonathan thinking no really what
is he thinking because this feels to me
like he has some crazy plan up his
sleeves already the first thing is Zoe
comes in to help Jonathan right off
right out the gate and she finds the
perfect property she was like combing
the streets like stuck in the
neighborhood and found in the perfect
one for me it's almost like I'm
competing me against the two of them so
it kind of backed out a little bit if I
didn't know she was an actor and a
singer I would assume that she was like
a 40-year veteran as a real estate agent
because she knows
that's actually amazing okay so Drew I
know you took you were the winner with
season seven do you go in with more
confidence or do you know Jonathan's
like you know ruling to take that title
back yeah can you say one more time that
I was the winner
your editors can edit that out that
would be great the team Drew
congratulations ah that was lame
I feel that I'm I'm strong enough to
take him down I'm confident in my game
but you'll see what happens this season
buy what you want where you want for
however much you want spend however much
you want and when we sell Whoever has
more profit wins it looks like you just
broke his brain there's something really
Head to Head
this place when he was gone
I have to change it to a confetti bomb
Jonathan interesting what's this
oh oh why he did that just after I
finish drywalling I was still finding
confetti everywhere